what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to kick start
our reactions for secret
invasion of course joined by John John
how are you great sir secretive koi
invading I read secret invasion in
preparation for this the whole time I
was reading I was going this is gonna be
nothing like this show there's a big
waste of time I might as well just
re-watch Captain Marvel and yet Good
comic Good comic though it was a fun
time but guys you know what to do leave
a like invade that like button also
subscribe and click the notification
Bell to get notified when our next
reaction for secret invasion is up here
in the channel and by the way did a
interview with the director of secret
Invasion I think he did an excellent
fantastic job I think people praise it
they said it was the best interview
Marvel has ever received ever feels good
feels good don't make it a secret share
it but guys before we go into this we
got a special word from our sponsor
fellow ring bearers this video is
brought to you by none other than
Electronic Arts the true Gandalf of
gaming they've crafted a new realm in
Lord of the Rings Heroes of Middle Earth
the game that's going to make you say my
precious this isn't just any game it's
your very own journey into Middle Earth
free for all Avengers Hobbits simply use
the link in the description box or pull
a Frodo and scan that QR code on screen
join the ranks of this tactical
turn-based squad builder amassing your
fellowship with Heroes like Frodo and
Sam Forge alliances that even the
Council of elrond would approve of and
dive head first into epic quests just
like Bilbo you'll stumble upon a
mysterious ring of power the timeline's
fracture and it's your job to fix the
broken Fellowship of time you might even
find history taking a different turn
perhaps Boromir won't try to take the
ring this time around here guess who's
stepping up to the plate elrond our very
own half Elven Lord he's coming to the
battle on June 26th the first of the
mighty legendaries with wisdom deeper
than the minds of Moria and power is
greater than Gandalf's fireworks he'll
Dazzle you his legendary Adventure event
began June 26th requires you to gather a
fellowship of five Elven characters if
you miss out don't worry there's always
more than one way to follow the
fellowship into Middle Earth so are you
ready to join the Battle of our time
creating dream teams facing formidable
foes exploring legendary locations and
forging new Destinies with your own ring
of power let's beat on the other side
and may the lights of Arundel guide your
path after all it's dangerous to go
alone take this that's a reference thank
you again for sponsoring this video oh
yeah real quick full-length Reaction
watch along We sync up with your own
copy of secretive agent available for a
super sexy rejects over our patreon page
but because this is the first episode
first one is public it is free for
everyone so there's a link in the
description box and pin comment you
could uh sync up with us over there if
you'd like let's do this
[Music]
sounds like an alien guys atmospheric
ethereal
Moscow hmm the fictional city of Moscow
presently sounds like Russian music
I'll be right there don't move imagine a
world where information can be trusted
this world
Society
starts to fray all we can turn to are
the people we care about one of those
people
weren't who we thought they were sounds
like Heath Ledger yeah there's been
mendelsohn Heathen agent Prescott five
Global terrorists strikes within the
past year Argentina tax Colombia
Colombia attacks the Philippines you
think the same people are behind all of
this not people
[Music]
Scrolls
Oh by name I love the presence of this
guy he's a lot it's
30 years ago when the Scrolls found
Earth Carol Danvers and Nick Fury
promised to find them a new planet now
they don't want just any Planet they
want ours they need Doctor Who Scrolls
could be anybody anywhere at any time
great Exposition and there is only a
tiny handful known to live on earth
you'll know God my damn what you're
talking about Ross
the Larry goes across like a conspiracy
theorist the only scroll contact has
been through Nick Fury there are allies
then where is Fury he's unsaver and if
I'm gonna bring him down I need to give
him something more than just theories I
need evidence
exciting Love The Dread is he a scroll
I'm wondering is Ross a squirrel this is
the one that sets the world on fire
it feels like a mission impossible movie
yeah
look I'm here to help so let me take
this and I'll give the information to
Fury oh he is bad
Oh no
you're letting the paranoia get the best
of you
[Music]
I don't know it's already messing with
my mind where's that green
whoa
whoa like his teeny weeny beanie
guess neither were Scrolls but it's
already got us paranoid yeah
wow he just casually
[Laughter]
I'm like a metro station six blocks
Northeast
[Music]
Zemo
it's just him
whoa
[Music]
cool Sean's so fast so different Martin
Freeman's stunt doubles yep I wanted his
floor and run
that's so comic book I love that look at
the purple shading I love it
[Music]
oh
ouch ah
show me your hands
rookie
Talos it's me
what the hell are you doing here
chasing him
well done show here's one of you nah
he's he's one of them
real Everett Ross better be safe
immediately like who
I'm so happy this is so good opening
credits wow
that's a beautiful artwork
I hope it's real artwork and not just
someone's AI Sim fair that was really
cool I really enjoyed that that's great
that might be one of their best ones
this is a really well conceived opening
credits setting the kind of theme and
style for the show yeah
[Music]
beautiful
it was a really well done shot
welcome back to Earth Welcome To Earth a
hug Nick Fury hugged
is that from home that's a scroll Sky
plan I am so sorry me too wow much
softer side of Nick after the blip you
were different and they disappeared Cal
Danvers disappeared your daughter
disappeared to where you're young angry
though people still don't have a home
she went to Amsterdam ravik is now the
newest member of the scroll Council he
preys on the collective Rage of young
displaced Scrolls where is his ass I
like that
smart scrolls are immune to
radioactivity and Russia has the most
abandoned nuclear plants on Earth
really
smart Prescott had been monitoring a new
radical group called the AAR Americans
against Russia which he believed to be
the next scroll front for a terrorist
attack not creative name at all
Americans against Russia
and he's going to use this bomb to do it
does he have the materials for that a
weapons cache in Kazakhstan raided the
same day that priscott was killed very
nice if he succeeds your species of
cease to exist
no
going for a walk you're going for a walk
in Moscow at night yeah oh you're gonna
stand out
counting on it I love that we have a
situation Mr President concerning agent
Fury who just received word that he's
left saber there he is he's left yeah
Derma moroney
that's it president
Fury is building out the most complex
Aerospace defense system in the history
of mankind there's a guy back there that
looked like Trump
yes
wanted to get caught
just like issue number one in the comic
[Laughter]
ah damn and I was hoping for a Command
Performance of Old Man River
you have some sort of clock fetish that
you've been keeping from me all these
years
yes I might have welcomed you home but I
still haven't forgiven you for
destroying my very expensive flat you
mean City
what are you doing in Moscow trying to
kill this girl rebellion in his crib you
know the rebel either personally don't
you I'm
is that why you came down from your
space station you feel responsible don't
answer that what
what no about a heist at a black market
storage facility in Kazakhstan doesn't
ring a bell liar you know damn well what
was in that storage for the fact that
you don't know tells me all I need to
know about this new rather old Nick Fury
I think thanos's snap changed you taught
you that no matter how hard you fight
for what's right there's always someone
stronger to undermine you ah I mean this
as a friend Fury but go back to your
space station you're in no shape for
this fight that lies before us I'll have
one of my thugs to drop you back at Safe
House the show's moving I know
I love how his performance as the wear
and tear of someone who's truly
traumatized by the blip and something
that we've been kind of crazy
and it's all in Snapchat
this feels more grounded than the rest
of the five years
thank you
Sarah Connor
take your natural form yeah don't be
ashamed of Who You Are
cool welcome to New skrillos what's it
called
scrappingopolis
what's your name Peter when's the last
time you ate I don't know
it's called me it's a four course meal
in the glove box these are struggles
we grow only scroll produce here drink
scroll wine West Royal skins whatever
dangers you risk getting here no they're
worth it so you can just put this word
scroll in front of anything yeah this is
her scroll mobile yeah
so our scroll headquarters look at them
endearing us to our leadership ways
caring for the people I don't trust her
I'm not ready to hate her for hating us
the cinematography of the show is
grounded but excellent
so I score really emotional yeah graphic
provides Refuge but if you do choose to
be a warrior there is one advantage you
get to leave everyone else stays in the
compounds the longer we attach to our
shells the less likely we can be
identified by humans and Scrolls alike
good fact good facts travel the world
travel the world meet interesting people
and kill them
home
bring in the show oh the shell take his
face
neat so can you like take their memories
with that thing or something as like a
constant link yeah I'll take his mind
sweet
thank you
but the immediate threat Remains the
bombs five specialists in Moscow are
capable of building such an explosive
Vasily population former Chechen Rebel
owns a high-end Gallery in the city
center and in a rave now what do you
mean wait until a scroll level picks up
the devices in order to follow them to
their Hideout then yes I totally agree
does she see an ugly ass squirrel like
you then she goes into hunting mode I'm
considered good looking amongst my
kindly well I know a bunch of good
looking squirrels
you talking about attacking MI6
operatives we're on a race with Sonja
Falls work she will annihilate any and
everyone who's ever even heard the name
ravik you want to save innocent Scrolls
you're going to have to hurt some people
don't be a pacifist Mercy is your
weakness
time for you to prove them wrong
let's try cards check first no mercy
they've done such a good job making the
scroll like duplicitousness work he said
take a drink said duplicitousness
[Laughter]
I'll go tell everyone we go tomorrow and
we don't stop until Earth Is Ours you
come with me it's time to serve your
country you take the cash to this
address you deal with population and no
one else he'll give you two bags you get
them to the Moscow safe house on the
store and intact
maybe a million Clark's all right so far
so good she's a really cool presence
like I'm very intrigued by her the whole
time
give oppression duh
oh [__]
that was easy not even 40 in human years
you haven't even gone on my mid-life
crisis shopping spree yet
oh there's time what you get for yours
The Avengers
what a great way to reference something
that isn't out of tone that was perfect
I'm late for an appointment oh who are
you meeting with my wife this is nice
there belong to Louis XV yeah it has an
ex-wife so we're gonna go ahead and call
that a lie
who are you going to meet who does
number two don't be more comfortable in
the gallery space where there is more
natural light oh you got any more than
comfortable ass Louis 14 chairs in there
how about dirty bomb I do not know this
term lie number two you're going to
shoot me maybe well probably
not right now
[Music]
there we go yes
Thanos oh
[Music]
oh
I got this is you
whoa
[Music]
come on yes
don't kill him tell me where the bombs
are three on people wow
it's gonna go well
girl fight yeah
[Music]
how'd you hurt Maria Hill
where'd you go she oh
killer Talos no questions asked change
your terms
last warning
it's what you always say but there's
always another
are you angry this is not what your
mother would have wanted her last words
fine Gaia huh why don't you ask people
that you work for
um
I can't you know that I'll protect you
you can't protect anyone gaiah
you're letting Gwen get away
[Music]
attempted are you to keep saying Duality
with all these complex layers that keeps
a lot of Duality Greg
it's almost a show about it
purple and green being opposite sides of
the spectrum of color correct
[Laughter]
it is
I love how they were having that in the
mirror
yes making friends with the locals how
do you think we kept the Cold War from
going hot
lots of like groups like me
[Laughter]
can't believe a Marvel show just had
that joke you gonna move I haven't
decided see that's what I'm worried
about the fury I knew was always three
steps ahead you've changed man
[Music]
that's right I think Nick Fury had a
child with a scroll kids definitely the
attack is planned for tomorrow Unity day
oh there are three bombs and graphic
knows you'll be there fracking pods most
of their identities are kept secret even
from us there are three careers
including me audit points near vocity
Square I just know if I could trust her
I love how brutal all the dialogue is
you just like shut her down with like
that was wonderful
yeah they're gonna mix up the plan good
disguise Nick glasses more glasses wow
Maria Hill no class step it up Maria
come on tell us if I was you I would uh
shape-shift into someone else no he's
got glasses on
I like how they've upgraded from the
Marvel hat
guys painted ours with infrared spray
infrared got it
got one carrier going Northeast the
other one's South they're all decoys
Follow That Girl cool
[Music]
they didn't shape-shift with items in
their hands too I think so I just don't
think they can use them as the like a
purpose like they can't make a gun
[Music]
oh Showdown
thanks
it's empty or decoys
Fury's gonna be the only one that's got
an actual mark
oh
[Music]
wow oh dude
just shoot into the crowd Fury yes
[Music]
oh you lost your specs no no
no no no no no
[Music]
no
oh oh my God do not kill Maria kill
Maria on the pilot of the new show
wait a minute that's more bombs so they
can turn them into guns
no oh you gotta be kidding me whoa
oh no not cool no
yeah yeah it sucks what I'm not happy oh
God what a cold shot too
I was literally like five minutes
thinking ago thinking that oh this is
really cool that we get to see like Kobe
smolders really get a chance to shine as
Maria Hill in a more serious role she's
so good she's so good they really just
kill one of the best actresses I like
that choice
yeah Sam I'm holding out hope that it's
some kind of mislead or some kind of
some sort of Espionage like I get it
raises the stakes and shows I understand
the choice but the narrative choice but
not the character Choice part of me it's
like but come on we finally got a show
where we really get a chance to hang out
with Maria Hill I've kind of I just love
Kobe smolder's take on her that would
have been really special
yeah a little back and forth on that
choice
oh well
no fridging is good you guys always the
move
her dead body will be in the thumbnail
yep I think that'll go over well for
everyone I think that'll be the way to
get happy so we get clicks it's all
about the clicks or with the dead body
with a big arrow pointing to the wound
how was I supposed to snowy to watch the
show you even though that there's
tomorrow or whatever wow bold choice
that pilot was absolutely incredible I
don't think there's gonna be a post
credit scene
which is Maria he'll wake it up
Nick
[Laughter]
Maria Hill will return
well [__] you Marvel whoa
that was
saving so it's interesting as our first
Marvel reaction the three of us have
done together where we were a lot more
serious than usual I'm so invested in
such a serious show and they really
delivered on the seriousness that felt
very it's very fascinating to me to take
one of the biggest event comic book runs
with a bunch of Marvel characters it is
just craziness and then they go how are
we gonna make the most grounded show
yeah yeah I've heard Disney pleasure out
of this massive event a true adaptation
of sorts
um Johnny what did you think my friend
lay it on the line I enjoyed it I
thought it was a solid start and and I
mean yeah I like it makes a lot of sense
a story like this to go for these Cold
War you know secret agent Espionage
spycraft sort of story and uh at least
thus far I'm very intrigued I mean you
know they're just setting the stage so
there's plenty more twists and turns to
come but I like just re-acquainting with
the fury and Maria Hill R.I.P and Talos
and all that stuff and uh yeah just
loving the I don't know the feeling the
vibe the aesthetic the setting you know
being sort of immersed in this Russian
environment I think is a nice change of
pace from from everything and yeah it
seems like at least at the outset
they're willing to have along with you
and your Intrigue some interesting
little you know semi-relevant
conversations and whatnot so uh thus far
I'm intrigued it's really interesting
how's this kind of King to conquer koi
take it away uh I think my favorite
thing is actually the the pace and tone
is it really trust the audience to let
us have so much dense dialogue that's
Exposition heavy but it's delivered so
incredibly well that not only did it do
the thing that I thought wouldn't happen
till two or three episodes in where it
is able to explain what the scrolls are
so upset about that they're willing to
change where we left them so many people
were like wait the Scrolls were good
guys at the end of Captain Marvel I
didn't think within the First Act of the
first episode I'd know everything I
needed to know about setting up secret
Invasion that's all through incredible
writing and directing where it doesn't
feel frenetic it doesn't feel rushed it
doesn't feel
um paced poorly in dialogue or style we
talked about cinematography but overall
the actual tension in the show comes
from the concepts like you you know the
stakes you know the World building
because it's giving you Exposition in
almost every scene but the concepts are
so heady and the world is so uh
aggressive that it doesn't ever feel
like it's about two people talking in a
room and it is like this show is very
much sitting and talking and it's that's
what good spy shows are to me and they
nailed a really unique tone that I did
not know they could
um this is up there with like the Loki
pilot for me and Loki's my favorite show
so like this is a really special debut
uh one division's up there as well but
like those are the ones that are the
most different like the Loki was so
existential and Wanda division was so
mysterious this is is so
spy Cold War you mentioned missed
impossible we mentioned a bunch of
things I I didn't know that that Marvel
would I mean there was there were so
many jokes in here I was like that is an
adult joke like they really went with
not a Disney plus audience here I'm
really impressed yeah but the jokes are
still within the character 100 there's
nothing jokey it's jokes that are like
you'd have in a cold war there's nothing
that feels that that Marvel humor
complaint that people have often lobbied
against the MCU you don't get any of
that here at all I love Fury post blip I
love that IT addresses so many things
that I wish they'd addressed sooner yeah
they really do they give you this this
really clever way of setting up Nick
Fury where it's
see what's cool about we're talking a
lot about plot and mood and atmosphere
all these things what they did an
excellent job at doing because the
exposition makes sense that you're
dealing with a lot of government
bureaucracy a bunch of different people
and factions and alliances so you have
to spout the exposition because there's
Mission driven so you have to give the
exposition so it's well Justified but at
the same time it's so character driven
everything everything is motivated by
character choices and then the the
personal feelings that everyone has like
I love the position that Talos is in of
he does not want a war whatsoever and
he's he's sympathized and he cares even
for the people that he's against like
the last thing he wanted to do was kill
that scroll who was on the opposite side
of his belief system and it you see that
it puts him at odds with the way how Sam
Jackson decides to handle it or Nick
Fury decides to handle with actually
killing him he's really bothered and
disturbed by it the last thing he wants
is death for any of his people because
despite the difference in beliefs he
doesn't want any of them to die so I
love the position that puts Talos in but
for Nick Fury especially what they did a
really great job at doing normally Nick
Fury no matter if he's gone Rogue or it
is at the top of the agency you feel
like in some way this guy's in control
in some way this guy's got a mastermind
position and you could see that he is a
lot of people keep commenting on it he's
not the Nick Fury that he used to be and
that's more than just like I'm grizzled
and and more Rough Around the Edges
that's it he he lacks in certain ways
because there's there's conflict within
himself there's a lack of confidence
within himself as well as he's you know
dusting off the old
fill in the phrase John Dustin off the
old the old Earth body or something you
know what I mean he's getting back into
the field you know the saddle yeah yeah
that's where I'm trying to go with that
yeah because with Nick Fury they they
put him in a position where I I find
myself actually rooting for him instead
of going he's got this handled and I
thought that's how I might feel like
he's got this handle he's gonna say some
like badass [__] I love that he's
actually an underdog and they he's not a
full Underdog but he's just enough of an
underdog and yeah the way how they deal
with the post-blip situation with his
performance I wonder whose choice that
was because that's something that
they've acknowledged about post split
that they've talked about and like sir
like Falcon Winter Soldier tried doing
it when you know he's trying to get a
loan up with it comedically yeah but
they don't really this is the first time
like wow the performance here is so
human of like this is the this is the
Disturbed character that I've been
waiting to see after such a horrendous
event you know that that happened within
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and I love
that it's a movie one actor I love that
it's Nick Fury who we've been with for
so long who we care about so much Sam
Jackson who we're invested in I really
love that the exemplification of the
trauma of the blip is is through new
fury because I wouldn't have expected
that like I I love that we've been
wanting something and a lot of times
Marvel does a good job being like this
is the character that embodies this
whole thing you want yeah I'm really
surprised and impressed it's Nick Fury
I'm really enjoying this performance
yeah and uh Olivia Coleman Estonia I
thought was an excellent scene as well
there's just a great writing and
character scenes throughout that's what
bummed me out so much about Maria Hill
dying at the end of this I really wanted
her to get to play because this yeah
that's the feeling like Kobe smolders I
really wanted Kobe to get to play like
it's about her I really kept feeling
like damn this is so cool we finally get
to see Kobe's Smothers
well she has such presence like her
performances are really great and and
she has just so you can tell she's
thinking Maria Hill thought she's fully
embodied the character and it's just
such a bummer to have the prospect of
not getting to watch more of that
because you know like a lot of people
obviously know her from How I Met Your
Mother but she can like really act I
know from Jack reach would never go back
of course that's right well and I mean
she worked her ass off to try and save
that like she's she's good in that bad
movie but like she's great well John uh
what did you think about Amelia Clarke
as Gina oh yes Rodriguez
I liked her so far I mean Emilia Clark
is an actor who I'm still waiting to
really click into so that's right man no
I don't want any women on these shows
all right that little girl with the ball
is too much for me in fact I want men
dressed as women like Shakespeare
intended yes but yeah I mean like as the
outset of the mission and for her
relation obviously the conflict between
her and Talos and finding out about the
death of her mother and everything like
you know there's lots for that character
and I like wondering if she's a double
agent yeah um and I mean her presence
just performance wise I think is good so
far you know again I'm still waiting to
be like I want to have those I want to
be talking about Emilia Clarke like I'm
talking about Kobe smolders right now
and I'm sure you know hopefully over the
show we'll get there but right now I'm
fitting introduction at the very least
well I really liked her scenes with Ben
Mendelson specifically I bought the
father-daughter relationship I like the
duplicitousness
itself
to these words
it is certainly that because yeah it is
cool though with the Scrolls that they
it there is truly truly literally not
just physically but emotionally all
around uh and I'm excited to see Amelia
Clarke's uh roll grow here at Olivia
Coleman I thought was a nice presence
that opening see you know what really
surprised me about it was I was
expecting something that just kind of
reminded me of Winter Soldier in its
tone because it's Marvel and at first I
thought like ah am I liking this more
like Mission Impossible but as it played
out I likened it more to Old School
um Thrillers like Manchurian Candidate
or uh what's that Robert Redford all the
presidents yeah all the president's been
so good yeah that one uh like those kind
of or like slow horses
yeah those kind of spy movies and it was
less it's in fact I started getting like
action heavy I was like oh yeah yeah
yeah
I was more surprised by that because
yeah I imagine there'll be they got two
tones that they're dealing with here you
got like an Invasion of the Body
Snatchers type of flare and close
encounters obviously but then you got
they lean way more heavily into the uh
negative isn't it no I don't know yeah
a duality of tones it's just extra
enhancement
yeah that was that was a good show I was
really impressed with uh not only are
they improving I think on the comic I
like secret invasion in the comic but I
don't think it's like uh I just don't
love event comics and
and the book feels very much like it
needed to be an event this feels like
the corner of Marvel I've been waiting
for it's actually improving on the event
feeling of the comic because I think
that the grounded level Marvel is much
more interesting than Cosmic for me A
lot of times yeah uh and what they're
able to do here is is really make the
most uh a supernatural thing an alien
invasion the most grounded show yeah I'm
so impressed fascinating duality
all right well before we end this drone
what you think of the music I like the
music quite a bit I thought it was uh
nice it wasn't two in your face but it
definitely bolstered those classic Vibes
you're talking about
uh I'm gonna have to hear more of it to
really kind of log the the flavors of
the show but thus far I thought it was
good it enhanced everything without
distracting me at any point uh but what
do you think about the Pod security
scroll played by uh James McNaughton my
favorite character listen up all right
there's a whole other conspiracy that's
going to link to this one specific
character so keep a lookout for pod
security scroll moving forward because
he's gonna be the key to everything and
uh you call I called it so just when
that happens I want you all to
acknowledge
you know that I called it all right well
I'm just excited it looks like Grace
Boyle who's an acting double got an
actual role a White House age has
promoted so I like any time a little uh
day player role gets happening so
congratulations Grace Boyle
don't worry guys
alrighty guys I love the show well what
did you think about our Premiere episode
of secret invasion was there not enough
Marvel comedy for you there's not enough
CGI action for you great to see Don
Cheadle how does this tie into the
Multiverse Marvel doesn't have a plan
what's going on here look at your
thoughts down below subscribe leave a
like
[Music]